كل ممر في كل ركن وكل جناح
وكل شبر من مركز مستشفى بروكديل
الطبي في بروكلين الآن غارق في
أولئك الذين يعانون من كوفات 19 ما
الذي تنظر إليه يوميًا مدى
صعوبة هذا جيدًا هذه منطقة حرب
إنها منطقة حرب طبية كل يوم.
تعال إلى ما أراه يوميًا هو
معاناة اليأس من الألم وتفاوتات الرعاية الصحية
حتى بعد ظهر يوم الأحد ،
قال Brookdale إنه لديه ما لا يقل عن 100
حالة مؤكدة من kovat 19 مع ما يقرب من
80 حالة في انتظار التأكيد ، وقد توفي أكثر من 20
شخصًا حتى الآن بسبب المرض بالإضافة
إلى  يدفع فيروس كورونا للتدفق الطبيعي لحالات الطوارئ
المستشفى
إلى أقصى الحدود ، نحن خائفون لأننا نقاتل من
أجل حياتك ونكافح من أجل
حياتنا الخاصة نحاول إبقاء
رأسنا فوق الماء وعدم إغراق
الممرضات والأطباء حتى هؤلاء  الحفاظ على الأرضيات
نظيفة لمواجهة المد المتصاعد غير مؤكد كم من
الوقت سيرتفع.
نحتاج للصلاة ،
نحتاج إلى دعم ، نحتاج إلى
قفازات ، نحتاج إلى أقنعة ، نحتاج إلى المزيد من الفتحات ،
نحتاج إلى المزيد من المساحات الطبية ، نحتاج إلى
دعم نفسي اجتماعي ، كما أنه ليس من
السهل المجيء إلى هنا عندما تعلم
أن ما تستعد لمواجهة الوفيات
هنا  استمر في القدوم أثناء تصوير
ضحية أخرى لـ kovat 19 ، تم نقله إلى
المشرحة المؤقتة بالمستشفى ،
نصف مقطورة مبردة متوقفة في
الخلف ، تملأ موري العادية بالمستشفى
إلى الحد الأقصى من
المساحة المتوفرة في المشرحة الخاصة بك ، وعادة ما يكون لدينا
حوالي 20 جثة إضافية يمكننا استيعابها
بشكل مريح وقد
تجاوزت ذلك ،
وكانت الدولة كريمة بما يكفي
لإحضار جهاز للمساعدة في الحفاظ على العائلات
والحفاظ على الأجساد والمناطق المريحة
لأننا لم نرغب في
تكديس الجثث فوق بعضها البعض.
كل شيء اليوم
قال إدوارد أن المستشفى به 370 سريراً
كانوا يرغبون في إضافته
قبل أسبوعين ، كانت هذه
غرفة طوارئ الأطفال الآن مخصصة
لضحايا كوف.  في 19 قطعة قماش بلاستيكية مثبتة
في السقف توفر بعض
الحماية وقليلًا من الخصوصية ، تملأ وحدة العناية المركزة
تقريبًا حتى السعة
وتغلق أبوابًا أقل وحركة مرور أقل
من المعتاد.
شخص واحد داخل الوحدة
أثناء الدردشة معهم عبر الهاتف الخلوي ، يكون
أحيانًا أقرب ما يمكن أن يصل إليه حيث
يأخذ kovat 19 حياة أخرى قاتمة
كما هي الآن
د.  يتوقع البوري أن يزداد الأمر سوءًا
في الخريف ، ولكن قد ينتهي في
نهاية العام ، لكن هذا هو السبب في أننا
نتوسل للجميع ليس فقط لممارسة
هذا الضغط على قسم الطوارئ
ولكن أيضًا للجميع
لمساعدتنا  من خلال البقاء في المنزل ،
تعتقد أننا في شهور طويلة وليس
أسابيع بالتأكيد شيء مقلق آخر
رأته يأتي إلى الأبواب ليس فقط
كبار السن وأولئك الذين يعانون من ضعف في
جهاز المناعة ، فأنا أعمل في مستشفيين ،
لذلك أعمل هنا في بروكلين ثم أنا "  لقد
عملت في مستشفى آخر في
برونكس وهو نفس الشيء في جنوب
برونكس وهو نفس الشيء الذي كان لدي
مرضى في الثلاثينيات
وهم الآن تحت الأنبوب وهم
مرضى حقًا.
لا توجد مواقف أساسية ، لذا فإن
الأمر يتعلق بين الحياة والموت
وبقدر ما أن هذا الفيروس التاجي هو
أن هذا الفيروس يرجى العلم أنه لا
يوجد فرق لا
علاقة له بالعمر لا علاقة له بنقص
الوصول إلى الرعاية الصحية  لا علاقة
له بعرق الاقتصاد الاجتماعي أو العرق ،
هذا الفيروس يقتل الكثير من الناس
لدى Brookdale ميزة واحدة
يقول مسؤولو المستشفى إنه يمكنه إجراء اختبار سريع
لفيروس كورونا في الموقع في مختبره الخاص
الآن حتى 300 اختبار في اليوم
يأملون في الوصول إلى 500  في اليوم ،
لدينا حوالي 52 عينة
هنا حوالي اثنتين نستعد
للاختبار في الوقت الحالي في المستشفى
باتباع إرشادات مراكز السيطرة على الأمراض
حول من يحصل على الاختبارات المرغوبة ،
والمرضى الذين يتم قبولهم
لعمال الرعاية الصحية لفيروس كورونا المحتمل الذين يظهرون
الأعراض والأعراض على المدى الطويل
يختبر كل مريض عملية شاقة
وتستغرق وقتًا طويلاً ، من السهل جدًا
ارتكاب خطأ سهل للغاية ، فقط من
مليلتر إضافي من الكاشف يمكن أن يؤدي إضافته
إلى الجهاز إلى إفساد
الدفعة بأكملها بالكامل ، جميع 50 تعليقًا
يجب أن نبدأ من جديد  منذ
البداية
، اعتاد أطباء الطوارئ على التأكيد على د.
تقول البوري إنها لم تختبر شيئًا
كهذا من قبل ، ولا أعتقد حقًا أن ذلك جيدًا
، وأنا قلق بشأن عائلتي ، أنا قلق
بشأن سلامتي ،
أنا قلق بشأن زملائي ، أشعر بالقلق
بشأن الكيفية التي ستكون عليها السفينة في
المرة القادمة التي أتيت فيها ، أشعر بالقلق  حول ما إذا كان أحد
أفراد الأسرة سيأتي ويكون
مريضًا وكذلك لضحايا
الفيروس التاجي ، فأنا قلق بشأن الكثير من
الأشياء مثل المرض ، وهو ماراثون
لا يمكن للعاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية بمفردهم الفوز به أو
حتى إنهائه ، فالأمر لا يقتصر فقط
على  يجب على أقسام الطوارئ أن تتقدم
وتتأكد من أن المنحنى
مسطح وهذه مسؤولية
الجميع في الدولة لمساعدتنا
على المضي قدمًا ، لذا ابق في المنزل
تمامًا لأنه
يتصرف تمامًا لأنه ليس علينا فقط وليس
فقط علينا المساعدة في التسطيح  منحنى
والاعتناء بالجميع ساعدنا على
مساعدتك تقول إن الأمر سيستغرق من
الجميع معًا في أسوأ الأيام التي
تخشى أن لا تزال أمامنا
ميغيل ماركيز سي إن إن بروكلين نيويورك